you had Hillary Clinton literally
calling her a spy and Mitt Romney
calling her treasonous she actually
talked about that
more recently U.S senator Mitt Romney
accused me of treason
a crime that is punishable by death
under our laws
I challenged him to back this back this
serious allegation up
with evidence what was this based on
there was no response
no explanation no evidence and certainly
no apology
now these accusations
are often Shrugged off as well hey it's
politics
people say things about each other all
the time that may be easy for some of
you to say but
for somebody who wears a uniform this is
serious and it's serious not only to me
but to my fellow service members and
Veterans every one of us making a
decision at some point in our lives to
raise our right hand
prepared and volunteering to lay our
life down for this country I love what
she said right there because she's
connecting her political service to her
military service and when you as she
points out when you go into the military
you don't know if you're coming back
alive you don't know if you're coming
back maimed or wounded you don't know
what mission they're going to send you
out on and when you go up there as a
politician you know they're going to say
the worst things about you but really
think about it which that woman Chelsea
gabbard was running for president
Hillary Clinton literally said she was a
Russian asset and nobody called Hillary
out on it it was just oh oh that's what
Hillary said you're allowed to do that
and that's what tulsi's saying it's like
you can say these things in politics
Mitt Romney had no reason to believe
that Tulsi is treasonous Tulsi just
doesn't buy the uniparty stuff that you
believe in I mean Rama you pretend
you're a republican but you you're
really a Democrat obviously and it's
kind of funny because we can link that
to the girl that used to work for you
Alyssa Farah Griffin I mean this is
these people the machine loves
Republicans who are really Democrats
right so if you are a republican if
you're a republican quote unquote who
will go on TV and constantly bash and
lie about your own side they love you
whether that's Mitt Romney whether
that's Liz Cheney and by the way the
woman that they flashed to you probably
recognized her while Tulsi was speaking
was congresswoman Harriet Hageman who
we've had on the show before who
replaced Liz Cheney a republican who
would only go on TV and be lauded and
applauded because you would attack
Republicans so this is how the machine
operates the machine operates by always
running cover for the Democrats bringing
on Republicans who will take out their
side and then hiding
Democrats when need be
[Music]